expansion across the valley nothing new
but some Sky Canyon residents speaking
out not in favor of a proposed
convenience store in the Northwest
Valley neighborhood stating that it
defeats the purpose of why they moved to
that part of town Madison Kimbrough
joining us from Grand Teton and Hualapai
now with more
well as a convenience store with gaming
and alcohol sales Las Vegas city council
to vote on this next month we moved here
because it was away from the city we
didn't move here to be
clogged and congested Andrea Leal upset
like so many other Sky Canyon residents
about the potential for a new Green
Valley grocery in their neighborhood she
and fellow neighbor Don Miller feel as
if the Planning Commission is not
considering the resident's opinions to
them they don't think a project like
this will serve the community well but
instead hinder it it's going to be six
to eight pumps there's going to be
alcohol sales and gambling on site in a
convenience store we're not interested
in the trash we're not interested in the
noise or the congestion it's just an
inappropriate project we have
five gas stations within a mile and a
half to two miles of the proposed site
already Miller is concerned about the
increase of crime and pollution this may
bring as the proposed site is located
right in the middle of dense residential
housing they're going to generate a ton
of traffic with an RV sized Car Wash so
that to us means that we're going to
have a long stream of RVs idling on the
side of the road waiting to get into the
car wash right next to our houses city
council will vote on November 16th and
the special use permit for gaming and
alcohol will also be discussed if
approved it's up to the developer when
construction will start there is a
community meeting on how they can stop
this project the opacity council members
to attend it's open to the public and it
starts at six that's going to be located
at the sky Canyon master plan Community
Center in Sky Canyon Madison Kimbrough 8
News Now